désormais le prêt de documents se fait
en self service à la médiathèque jacques
brel de magny les hameaux qui a rouvert
le 27 février après un mois de travaux
ces travaux de modernisation
s'inscrivent dans un projet global de
950 mille euros financé à 70% par l'état
et la région et qui concernera tout le
réseau de médiathèques saint-quentinoise
l'équipe de la médiathèque à encoder les
23000 documents que nous avons au fond
c'est à dire que nous avons apposé sur
chaque document de la médiathèque une
étiquette rfid c'est une étiquette
d'identification par radiofréquence
simple qui permet en fait d'automatiser
les transactions au sein de la
médiathèque jacques brel
les 2500 adhérents peuvent désormais
emprunter livres cd et dvd de manière
autonome il tâtonne encore sous l'oeil
bienveillant des médiathécaires c'est ma
première fois donc j'ai un peu galéré
pour pour la carte d'adhérent mais après
j'ai eu les des explications de la
bibliothécaire donc ça s'est bien passé
maintenant c'est dommage si du coup il
ya moyen du bio tekere au niveau
contacter le contact sera paradoxalement
renforcer l'automatisation permet aux
quatre médiathécaires rester en poste de
se consacrer davantage à leur coeur de
métier la médiation culturelle
nous sommes affranchis de tout ce qui
était matérialisation en fait tout ce
qui était transaction document
des antilles volage des documents pour
justement pouvoir mieux renseignés
pouvoir être présent d'accompagner de
répondre aux sollicitations des
adhérents donc c'est celle avantages de
cette automatisation
l'autre nouveauté est la mise en place
d'une boîte de retour automatique 24
heures sur 24 à l'extérieur dont le
design ressemblant distributeurs de
billets elle devrait être opérationnelle
en septembre quand la totalité des
médiathèques du réseau sera uniformisé
par le système de puce la médiathèque
anatole-france de trappes et la
prochaine à se moderniser
elle sera fermée au public du 2 au 29
avril pour une réouverture le 30